let's take a look tonight at gina Haspel
who is she
here's national security correspondent
jennifer griffin live from the Pentagon
there are a few images of Gina Haspel a
career intelligence operative who worked
for years in the shadows leading the
hunt for the world's most wanted
terrorists last March as deputy director
of the CIA
she sat two seats down from defense
secretary Jim mattis as he welcomed the
Saudi Crown Prince to the Pentagon if
confirmed she will be the first woman to
head the CIA she joined the agency in
1985 she's 61 years old and was once the
deputy director of national clandestine
service she oversaw covert action and
ran the CIA black site in Thailand known
as cat's-eye where Abu Zubaydah was
waterboarded in 2002 along with abdul
rahim al-nashiri best known for the USS
Cole bombing both remain at Gitmo she is
someone who was up to our eyeballs in
the torture issue she was in charge of
the CIA torture site in Thailand a place
where one man was waterboarded 83 times
Hospital wrote the cable ordering the
destruction of waterboarding tapes in
2005 according to her boss national
clandestine service chief Jose Rodriguez
who wrote about it in his book quote the
cable left nothing to chance it even
told them how to get rid of the tapes
they were to use an industrial-strength
shredder to do the deed hospitals many
defenders say those black sites have to
be seen in context the Justice
Department and President Bush authorized
the actions the CIA believed at the time
the US was facing another major attack
in the wake of 9/11 Gina is somebody who
I have great confidence in can steer the
ship of state of CIA and having a
professional there having somebody who
is a political and nonpartisan and it's
not going to engage in policy I think
will be seen as a breath of fresh air a
lot of people at CIA Trump spoke often
during the campaign about reinstating
waterboarding the few in the CIA would
now support that I can tell you that
members of the paramilitary community
who conduct missions with the CIA have
welcomed Haskell's nomination
defense secretary Jim mattis is a big
proponent as well
bread you know Jen with all this
happening while secretary mattis is in
Kabul Afghanistan on an unannounced trip
interesting mattis is talking to
commander spread about how the military
strategy is proceeding and whether the
Afghan President believes reconciliation
talks with the Taliban could work you'll
remember the Taliban wrote an open
letter to the American public suggesting
as much on Valentine's Day
all wars come to an end you don't want
to miss an opportunity because you
weren't alerted to the opportunity so
you need to have that door open even as
you increase the military predator 17
years into the war and the defense
secretary still travels to Kabul in
secret the US and Afghan military have
not secured the Capitol reporters were
unable to report on the trip until
safely away from the flight line because
back in September the Taliban fired 40
rockets at a u.s. airbase an hour after
mattis landed mattis did not speak today
about the firing of his friend and
wingmen Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
Brett